New York City's Police Department the
largest in the country is being ravaged
by the corona virus more than 900 NYPD
employees including more than 800 police
officers have now tested positive our
lead national correspondent David Wagner
was following the impact on first
responders David what are they telling
you Gil get this EMS responders here in
New York City are getting nearly as many
calls today as they did on September 11
think about that for a minute and New
York's governor says we could be two
weeks away from what is the peak of the
virus here sounds of sirens in New York
City right now really stand out and
that's because it's so much quieter here
than normal
everyone has been asked to stay inside
this is the same outside my job right
now
this was the Lower East Side of
Manhattan on Monday a nurse from NYU
Langone Hospital sent us this video he
told us there were nine ambulances all
backed up trying to get patients into
the emergency room entrance we just
showed our viewers video of ambulances
backing up at the emergency room at NYU
Langone have you seen that every day
Anthony al majora is vice-president of
the New York City Fire Department's EMS
officers union he's also a lieutenant
paramedic I've never seen 7,000 calls in
EMS to give you some perspective that's
more than 911 so basically we've had
9/11 type calls for about eight days now
on Sunday FDNY ambulance mechanic james
valenko died after being infected with
the corona virus the FDNY says more than
260 of its members are currently
infected I have never seen anything like
this before
in my career or in my lifetime to be
honest lilly and bond senor is the chief
of ems operations for the FDNY it's
gotten to the point that the FDNY is
telling people this you are not
seriously sick if you are not having a
true emergency stay home save 9-1-1 for
those true emergencies when it comes to
the NYPD more than eight hundred police
officers are infected with the virus
four members have died including a
detective who was a 23-year veteran of
the force Dermot che is the NYPD
Commissioner we are hurting we are
crying and we continue to fight we
simply have no other choice
nearly fifty two hundred members of the
NYPD force are sick right now that's
about a 14% rate for them they usually
run a rate of 3% now most companies
including CBS for example I had to stay
home after being exposed to a co-worker
who had the virus most people would be
told if you're exposed stay home as a
precaution the NYPD is saying if you're
sick stay home
but Gail they're telling their members
if you've been exposed to someone with
the virus and you don't feel sick we
need you to keep working boy David it's
tough this coronavirus has affected
everybody as we know and listen you
don't want anybody to die but it's
always hard to me when I hear about
first responders who are literally
risking their lives to save strangers to
help others and in the process sometimes
lose their lives it's a very tough story
listen Gil we keep hearing that there
are first responders and emergency Bay
hospital rooms around the country who
take a moment to cry on the side because
they are working 15 and 16 hour days to
answer every call coming in well I hope
they know their work is appreciated
every night at 7 o'clock on my street I
think it's happening all over the city
actually people come out and give them a
round of applause and a cheer so I hope
they know how much their work is
appreciated and needed David thank you
always good to see you ahead the high
price yes we do